how's it going everybody it's warren
welcome back to my channel the cosmic
wonder where we talk all things marvel
and everything relating to the marvel
cinematic universe and the pandemic may
have slowed marvel studios down
stopping the production on everything
that they were working on at the time
including disney plus shows and movies
but marvel studios is back
at it and they're going full steam ahead
the falcon and the winter soldier is
back filming we have
our official she-hulk slash jennifer
walters the set for the loki series is
being built and filming is about to
begin soon and we have some
major miss marvel details today
including
two new casting calls for two very
particular characters and
including the hiring of not one but four
directors for the miss marvel series
coming to disney plus
and also the possible confirmation of a
new character that is going to enter the
mcu
in the miss marvel series so we're going
to break down everything about this news
that you need to know
in this video if you love the mcu be
sure to subscribe so you can stay up to
date on all the latest news and so you
can enter this week's giveaway for a
chance to win a scarlet witch funko pop
i'm picking a winner on monday
so as i mentioned not one but four new
directors have been chosen for the miss
marvel series
now this is awesome news in itself
because the directors really are
fantastic
the new director list includes the
directors for bad boys for life
directors adil l arby and bilal falal
two-time oscar-winning documentary
filmmaker charmin
abed chinoy and mira menon who has
directed episodes of the walking dead
and the punisher so truly great
directors for this show and if you're
wondering no they're not all going to
direct each episode altogether this is
going to be very much like the
mandalorian
on each episode of the mandalorian it
had a new
director and some people were worried
about this but it actually turned out
really really well
and it's not yet confirmed how many
episodes of miss marvel are going to be
on disney plus
or how many seasons but for right now
there are four directors who are going
to be directing
different episodes of the series now
this is big news because of course the
directors are huge
but this probably means that we're going
to figure out who they cast to play miss
marvel last week there was a rumor going
around that marvel studios had already
cast
jennifer walters aka she-hulk and kamala
khan
aka miss marvel as that rumor came out
another report came out stating that the
she-hulk series had found its director
then a couple of days after that we got
the official report that marvel studios
has cast
tatiana musslaney as she-hulk slash
jennifer walters
the fact that we got the casting for
she-hulk provides a lot of validity to
this rumor that she hulk
and miss marvel have already been cast
we then got the official news that
marvel studios has hired its directors
for the movie
and if they're going to follow the same
pattern that they did for she-hulk we
should be getting the casting call from
miss marvel any day now
so we have the new directors for miss
marvel and hopefully within the next few
days we'll figure out who is playing
miss marvel slash kamala khan now
casting has been
well underway for the miss marvel series
and just a few days ago we got word that
there is a new casting call for not one
but two
new supporting actors that comic fans
probably will recognize
the casting call used code names but it
seems like who they are casting are
kamala's friends
zoe zimmer and her eventual
sister-in-law taisha hillman
the studio is searching for a young
white actress between 16 and 20 years
old for zoe and a black actress between
27-33 for
taisha and as i mentioned in the
beginning it seems like the fandom has
discovered a new character that is going
to be appearing in miss marvel
in a report from mcu-cosmic.com it seems
like
some redditors have discovered this new
character in a discussion thread it
reads
honestly seeing all this hype for miss
marvel just makes me sad now i'm sure
it'll be great and i'm excited to see
who gets the rolls and rocks it
just kind of bummed i never got a call
back then somebody asked
you auditioned for kamala but he replied
red dagger
however i would have definitely heard
back by now if they were considering me
this actually coincides with a report
from the illuminerty.com
way back in february who said that red
dagger will in fact be in the show and
they also said that the inhumans are
going to be in the show as well
so if red dagger is in the show and it
kind of looks that way right now the
inhumans could be getting a reboot in
the mcu
now in the comics red dagger is kamala
khan's love interest
and a crime fighter in pakistan red
dagger's actual name is kareem and his
mother was friends with kamala khan's
aunt and then kareem at one point in
time
lived with the grandmother of kamala and
this is how kamala and kareem
meet kareem goes to school during the
day but at night he protects the people
of pakistan
as the hero red dagger now it would make
sense that kamala would have a love
interest
many of the mcu movies do with the
exception of captain marvel
so this combined with the fact that
somebody is claiming to have auditioned
for the role and the illuminati report
back in february
means that it could be very likely that
we see red dagger show up and
the in humans so a lot of news about
miss
marvel today let me know how excited you
are for this news and let me know who
you think would be a good fit to play
kamala khan miss marvel let me know your
thoughts in the comments
down below don't forget to like the
video and subscribe so you can stay up
to date on
all the latest mcu news for live updates
and for other giveaways you can follow
me on instagram and twitter and as
always thank you all so much for
watching
woof